et voilà comme les cinq mousquetaires
les trois mousquetaires non on sait pas
combien ils étaient en vrai tu sais que
les trois mousquetaires est une fiction
en fait écrite par alexandre dumas y en
a même qui disent ah de la bible
aujourd'hui qu'elle a été écrite par
alexandre dumas sera pas construit 20 de
la bible c'est de jésus ne se dessine
ils ne se sont pas vu depuis 20 ans mais
ce soir ils reviennent dans leur fief
pour finir la grande tournée des pubs
c'est l'occasion d'achever le marathon
de la voie maltée tous peuvent tous
points et cette fois ils tiendront la
route jusqu'à l'étape ultime
la fin du monde vous nous recommander la
bière servie dans 5 merci 4 et un verre
d'eau je vous prie ça fait un bail
gary ville comme bienvenue welcome c'est
bizarre non
rien n'a changé mais tout à leur
différend je vous suggère de passer
votre chemin
à votre tour messieurs c'est pas nous
qui avons changé c'est la ville tu fais
quoi là t'inquiète je vais pas essayer
de sauter il ya un truc qu'il faut que
je te dise tout de suite sauf si tu veux
qu'on s'envoie en l'air dans ce cas je
te le dis après douze mois tout de suite
il t'aide quassam newton events avait
envahi par des robots et tu l'a cru on
devrait rentrer à londres à on est
bourré on a les mains pleines de sang
c'est plus comme du linge en aliments
pleines dents par les créateurs de shaun
of the dead et de rohde faisait les
gouttières on descend par là j'ai une
meilleure idée les gouttières descend
par là ces moyens de survivre à la
dignité et de tenir jusqu'au dernier
club
poussons les autres ils fondent dans le
paysage salut je suis un robot on est
cinq potes
en virée et on est là pour s'éclater
le vernis pub avant la fin du monde
c'est quoi ce truc
rendez vous à la fin du monde quitte à
en mourir